and you know Peter Patrick mahomes had
kind of become the forgotten man this
year because of Lamar Jackson and the
San Francisco 49ers and he had the ankle
injury in week one which affected his
mobility
he had the knee injury that looked
extremely serious at the time when he
came back from it he wasn't the guy he
was last year and kind of quietly
without us really paying a lot of
attention he became the guy he was last
year and that guy's been back for the
playoffs and he is definitely back for
the Super Bowl and it's been kind of a
strange development that we went to
sleep on the Chiefs
the team that we all paid going into the
season as a Super Bowl favorite Mike I
think one of the really interesting
things about this game is that for the
first time since I've been watching him
play he showed the kind of emotion that
that he has been sort of a cool
character and we just showed the video
of him leaping up and down and jumping
up and down you saw him in the end zone
when DeMarcus Robinson was doing this to
him and saying we are not worthy
essentially and you saw the kind of
emotion and you saw what this meant to
him and talking to the Chiefs afterwards
talking to Andy Reed one of the things
that I divined from all these people is
that Patrick mahomes has now become the
kind of leader on this team that Andy
Reid can basically just put on automatic
pilot and I that's-- that's a little bit
of an exaggeration but he knows every
time that mahomes takes a snap that he
is going to do exactly what Andy Reid
Eric be enemy Frank Kafka want him to do
and that is a very comfortable feeling
for the Chiefs as an offensive staff and
one thing that really has blossomed in
the postseason although it doesn't say
much for the team's running backs the
fact that Patrick mahomes is leading the
Chiefs in rushing because as Andy Reid
explained earlier this week he
recognizes that the defensive backs and
the linebackers are so obsessed with
stopping
the receivers and tight end Travis Kelce
that it's creating these running legs
and Patrick mahomes added to it is screw
it I'll just run and we've seen that
athleticism that ability to stay
inbounds the full-body fake which was
primarily a head fake but the more I
watch that thing the more beautiful it
is that sprung that 27-yard touchdown
run that put the Chiefs ahead on Sunday
he will run and you better account for
that as you're trying to slow down
Travis Kelce Tyree kill Sammy Watkins
and the rest of their weapons Peter well
the interesting thing on this play that
you're seeing which is the run of his
life college or pro the interesting
thing about that as both he and Reid
talked about after the game is that
Patrick mahomes had two guys double
covered on that play now they are used
to having either Kelsey or Tyreke he'll
very occasionally Sammy Watkins but
Kelsey or Tyreke Hill doubled on this
particular play both were so imagine you
have Tyreke he'll chase and Kelsey
doubled and you're being spied OK by
Rashad Evans so now in the mind of
Patrick mahomes what he is thinking is
that okay I got three guys I got three
or four guys on my defensive front and
he said if if I've got four guys in
coverage on two receivers I'm gonna have
a lot of space to go do something and
that's exactly what happened on this
play he knew he had space and he knew he
had two timeouts left this is to me next
level thinking by a quarterback who in
my mind right now is the most dangerous
player in the playoffs and in that 27
yard touchdown run during which I think
I saw Gil Brandt tweet that he ran 60
yards to gain 27 he were 24 yards Mike
yeah if you're gonna spy him Sims and I
were talking about this yesterday
you can't spy him with Rashad Evans
you've got to spy him with someone who
has the ability to track him down and
tackle him because Evans fell for that
fake it just went flailing and that's
what opened the whole thing up
yeah and I think the Titans had a very
good plan going in I mean III think Dean
Pease has had a great playoff season to
end his career but I think it's a little
bit unrealistic to think with the
weapons that Patrick mahomes has and the
athletic ability that mahomes has that
you're gonna be able to stop them with a
linebacker as a spy and one other thing
Mike I think what is so cool about this
particular matchup is that mahomes is
gonna be chased so much it is going to
have to make so many plays when he's
uncomfortable when he's out of the
pocket but Patrick mahomes has made me
uncomfortable comfortable you know from
his no-look pass against the Ravens -
last year - is incredible downfield
throw when he was chased by za'darius
Smith threw into triple coverage and
completed it - Tyreke he'll watch how
many great plays he's made when the
pocket is broken down and that's why
this is going to be such a fun game
we're gonna see so many of those plays
because the 49ers force the pocket to
get broken down yeah and and it's
impossible not to peek forward I've
resisted it for now but when you project
to that 49ers defense we talked about
the spy they have more athletic
linebackers than rashon Evans you could
put a Quan Alexander in that spy
position and also Peter one thing that I
think we will see from the 49ers if
Patrick mahomes decides to take off as a
runner I don't think we will see that
that that tentative quality that we see
from too many defensive players who get
scared of what happens if I hit the
quarterback and and you know that's on
the brains of these guys and it needs to
be if they're near the sideline you
can't blow them up if they slide you
can't blow them up and you can never dip
your helmet and cram it into them but
some defensive players I think Peter are
coached far differently
Patriots defenders Seahawks defenders
and my guess is that Robert Solow the
defensive coordinator the 49ers is gonna
spend the next two weeks telling his
guys if this guy runs you
hit him and the Titans players
especially inside the five I don't know
what the hell those guys were doing but
they weren't hitting Patrick mahomes I
think it'll be a different experience
for him if he tries to run against the
49ers yeah I mean clearly tramaine Brock
made a stupid play at the 5-yard line
and he kept trying to strip the ball you
got to tackle him you just got to tackle
him and and too many people now in the
NFL in general I've had so many
defensive coordinators over the last
couple of years
like when I visit training camp and
everything I've had this pet peeve and
I'll say why is there such an emphasis
on the strip when so many running backs
and quarterbacks
I mean obviously you're gonna get some
of them but you give up so many yards
doing that right and and that is a look
I'm not saying the Chiefs wouldn't have
scored but I think Mike one of the other
things that I think Roberts al is gonna
do here is he's basically gonna say to
his defense you know you're absolutely
right when he is a runner you treat him
like a runner you don't treat him like a
quarterback you hit him and you hit him
hard yeah and you know what at a certain
level I think that and I want to be
careful here because I'm not suggesting
that they try to knock him out of the
game that's not what I'm saying but at a
certain point you trade the risk of 15
yards if you can send a message and
football is still a physical violent
game if you can hit him even if it's
close to the sideline even if he's maybe
started into his slide when when the
championship is riding on it I think
it's a different analysis and yeah we
may give up 15 yards or half the
distance to the goal line I mean that's
the thing Peter if somebody had blown up
Patrick mahomes inside the five okay it
goes from the four to the two big deal
so again I'm not saying that that should
be part of the deliberate effort but the
Super Bowl is riding on it and if this
guy's gonna think that he can just run
through the defense without any physical
consequence they needed to dispel him of
that notion the first time he tries Mike
I'm now gonna say a little bit counter
to what I just said because although I
think Robert Solow would be wise to do
that I think it'll have zero impact on
Patrick mahomes the quarterback since he
was in middle school he has been his
team's offense basically and he has been
used to people taking shots at him all
through high school all through college
and I just don't think that's going to
stop him or even deter him from playing
exactly the way he wants to play I think
he's got a little bit of Gumby in him
where he's not necessarily the fastest
guy but how many times have you seen him
take a huge hit it just doesn't happen
very much he can twist his body into
certain you know into certain ways so
that he doesn't take that big hit I
don't think he's gonna change if he gets
blasted a couple of times in the first
half of this game I do not think you're
gonna see him starting to run out of
bounds we've seen the Chiefs and mahomes
fall behind 24 to nothing against the
Texans 10 nothing and then 17 7 against
the Titans what is it about my homes
that you've seen that allows him to not
get freaked out because plenty of
quarterbacks would get freaked out when
you fall that far behind you feel like
you need to get it all back in one play
instead of just trusting hey I got this
we can do this we'll start chopping at
the tree and the trees eventually gonna
fall down Mike he's the AFC's Russell
Wilson because the one thing that I've
always thought about Russell Wilson is
that he never loses a game the clock
just runs out and that's the way mahomes
is I think he takes great delight in
saying ok we're down 10 I'll show you
and I know that sounds high schoolish
really it does but that's the way he
thinks that's the way Russell Wilson
thinks and they never think the game is
over now the one thing that's happened
in these two games early on is that
especially on special teams against
Houston that's what is a bothersome
thing about the potential of this game
in my opinion because I think that the
49ers they've got an excellent punter
and kickoff guy
Mich wish now ski and they've also got
potentially good return guys and I would
be even though Dave Tobi's a great
special teams coach for Kansas City I
would be very concerned that their
special teams in San Francisco that they
believe that they can get an edge in
this game and get an early lead we'll
see how that goes but my feeling is that
that's going to be against San Francisco
with that pass rush you don't want to
get down double digits early especially
when they have that running game that
meat-grinder of a running game which
will be working if the 49ers establish
that lead I mean that's the thing and
we're gonna be talking more about the
49ers over the course of the next two
weeks but the idea that we know fairly
early whether or not that running game
is gonna work and if it's working it's
not like you're gonna have a solution
for it it's either gonna work or it's
not and if it's working in the first
quarter it's going to be working all the
way through to the fourth quarter and if
you fall behind that very difficult to
come back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports